and now to Africa a continent with 58
countries and 1.2 billion people but
just town linked up are they less than a
third of Africans have internet access
most of them in South Africa Kenya and
Nigeria in 2015 there were 226 million
registered smartphone SIM cards however
that number is set to triple by 2020 and
that's influencing urban hipsters in
their choice of work Cape Town's
waterfront is prime real estate and a
perfect location for a business that's
what the founders if she leaves Africa
thought and set up their internet
platform to help young African women
achieve their professional dreams
it organizes workshops and events across
Africa on networking during up business
plans and marketing and PR strategies
this weekend toka Mia is running a
workshop on programming for young
entrepreneurs computer science and
software design is still very much
male-dominated fields so science
technology engineering and math
extremely important because in Africa
and I think it's a phenomenon around the
world women often are told you know
you'd be better at something else and
that's why we we focus on technology and
entrepreneurship getting people and
especially women and after
involved in tech and getting them
involved in entrepreneurship activities
getting them involved in key areas where
they could be in the CEOs Takamiya works
for girl hype a nonprofit organization
that aims to get more women into STEM
subjects her mother founded girl hype
twelve years ago the biggest challenge
is investments getting investments
getting endorsements getting
sponsorships
I think African women you really need to
come in with a sense of leadership
coming with a sense of ownership come in
with this is me this is what I do and
I'm capable it's not a it's not you know
leave the beggar mentality of her you
don't need to pick when you hear really
bring you any leadership some of today's
participants already run their own
websites nyaka Shabangu has an online
platform that promotes natural hair
users can buy products discuss tips for
hair care and find out about services an
event taking place
she's familiar with the challenges
facing female entrepreneurs to
government funding access to private
sector funding you know not being bold
enough to go into companies and say you
should hire me or I need to be working
here or you need to listen to me I think
that's possibly the biggest challenge
with women in South Africa particularly
Misha Tigana is head of communications
and public affairs at Google South
Africa she's confident that digital
technology will continue to create jobs
she also hopes it will allow African
businesses to forge their own paths I
think we're so obsessed with skill
because that's what the world of
entrepreneurship in the West has taught
us to believe in when you think about it
if I employ three people and one person
leaves my business because they equipped
enough to start their own business and
then they employ none of three people
and one person leaves the bad business
to go in for another three people when
that happens at a scale of 10,000 is
that
scaling the new opportunities aren't
restricted to the digital world job
creation is a priority in every sector
there's only someone jobs creating apps
Kin Kin Kin land give but if you can
build a farm that allows the Africans to
produce and solve their own food you've
created not just so many jobs that you
said so many people here in Cape Town
the digital future has arrived and women
are very much part of it